in this video you're going to learn how
to work with variation equations we're
going to talk about direct variation
inverse variation joint variation as
well as combined variation and we're
going to do this in six examples so
we're going to talk about how to work
with tables we're going to talk about
how to write equations we're going to
talk about how to use those equations to
find particular values so let's dive
into this variation video here so the
first example it says y varies directly
with X Y is equal to 8 when x equals 2
find out what Y is when X is equal to
10. now our general form of a direct
variation equation is this form here y
equals K times X or some teachers will
write this as y equals a times x k or a
is like your constant of variation it
tells us how X and Y are related to one
another so in this case if we know that
y
varies directly with x
let's start off with our general
equation and then it gives us some
information so Y is equal to E when X is
equal to 2. so let's substitute those
values in so we can solve for our
constant of variation if we divide both
sides by 2
you can see here that K is coming out to
4. so if we take that 4 and we put it
back in for k
we have y is equal to 4 times x that's
our direct variation equation now let's
use that direct variation equation to
find out what Y is when X is equal to
10. so I'm going to substitute 10 in for
x 4 times 10 is equal to 40.
and you got it let's take a look at
number two this one's an inverse
variation equation Y varies inversely
with X Y is equal to 12 when X is equal
to 3 find y when X is equal to 9. so
what I normally do is I start by writing
my general equation if it's inverse Y is
equal to K divided by X or you could say
y equals a divided by X but notice that
the variable here is in the denominator
with direct you can see that variable is
in the numerator so I would write this
as Y is equal to K divided by X when Y
is 12
X is equal to 3 so let's substitute
those values to solve for K instead of
dividing by 3 Let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 3.
so K is equal to 36. now you want to
take that 36 and put it back in for K so
now we have a more specific equation y
equals 36 divided by X find out what Y
is when x equals 9. so we're going to do
is replace x with 9
36 divided by 9 is equal to 4.
and you got it so I usually think of
this as three steps I think of my
general equation
as step one
then I give a more specific equation
I think of that as like step two and we
get that by substituting in the values
that they give us and then you use that
more specific equation to solve and I
think of that as like step three so
three steps let's take a look at example
number three okay for example number
three now we're given these two tables
okay two part question A and B and it
says
is it a direct inverse or neither
equation and can you find the constant
of variation K and can you write the
variation equation now what we want to
do is let's go to our direct variation
equation we have y equals K times x if
we solve for K that constant of
variation what we'd have to do is divide
both sides by X
to get that K by itself so Direct
you can think of that as if y divided by
X this gives you the same quantity each
time with that same constant of
variation then you're going to know it's
Direct
with the inverse variation equation see
how we have y equals K divided by X
here to get K by itself we have to
multiply both sides by X so you can see
that x times y should be giving us the
same constant A variation and that'll
tell us that it's an inverse
variation equation so let's go ahead and
take that information here and let's
test it out so if I do y divided by X so
3 divided by 1 gives me 3 6 divided by 2
gives me 3 9 divided by 3 is 3 12
divided by 4 is 3 and 15 divided by 5 is
3. so that tells me that this is
actually a direct variation equation and
our K value is equal to 3. so let's go
ahead and do that k equals 3 and our
equation is y equals 3 times x now
sometimes I like to test it out so if I
put 5 in oh yeah 3 times 5 is equal to
15 I know I got it right
for number letter B though let's do that
same thing y divided by X so 1 divided
by negative 12 that's negative 1 12 2
divided by negative 6 that's negative 1
3 if you reduce that's not the same
number so it's not a direct variation
equation let's try multiplying the X and
Y coordinates together negative 12 times
1 is negative 12. negative 6 times 2 is
negative 12 negative 12 negative 12
negative 12. so here what's happening
when we multiply the X and y's together
we're getting that same constant K and
so what that tells us is this is an
inverse variation this one here was
direct
so let's write down inverse variation
and our K value we set is equal to
negative 12. and if we write our
equation it's going to be y equals
negative 12 divided by X now we can
check it let's put in an x value
negative 2 negative 12 divided by
negative 2 yeah it matches 6. so you
know you got it right so sometimes
students get a little bit confused
because they say Mario I thought
directly we were multiplying K times x
how come we're dividing here you know
they think okay this is multiplying this
is dividing or with inverse they say oh
this is dividing but here we're
multiplying why is it the opposite the
reason it's different is because we're
solving for K we're getting that
constant by itself and so we had to
rewrite the equations to isolate that k
so great job if you could follow that
one now let's go to example number four
okay let's dive into example number four
now it says y varies jointly with x and
z
Y is negative 36 when x equals 2 and Z
equals 3 how can we find y when X is
negative 1 and Z is four now when they
say joint variation we're looking at
something that's in this form right here
y varies jointly with x and z and notice
you always have to have a consonant
variation whether that's k or a or
whatever variable that you want to use
there so in this case we've got y
varies jointly with x and z notice these
are all multiplied together they give us
some information Y is negative 36
when
X is 2 and Z is equal to 3. so all I'm
doing is just substituting in those
values so we can solve for K our
constant of variation so here we're
getting 6 times k equals negative 36
divide both sides by 6 and you can see
that K is coming out to negative 6. so
let's go ahead and put that back in for
k
so we have y equals negative 6 times x
times Z I like to put a little line
through my Z so I don't think it's a
number two
and then now it says find out what Y is
when x equals negative one
and Z is equal to 4. so we're going to
substitute those values in so we have y
equals negative six
times negative 1 times 4 which gives us
24.
and you got it so if you want to process
you know what I like to do is thinking
of three steps I like to think of okay
write my general solution
then I substitute in the given values
solve for K put it back in this is like
a more specific equation that we can use
and then now use that more specific
equation to solve so kind of like three
steps let's take a look at example five
and six where we talk about combined
variation right a combined variation
model for number five and number six so
number five says y varies directly with
the square root of x and inversely with
the cube root of Z so this is combined
meaning it could be a combination of
more than one type now let's start off
here y varies directly now direct means
it's in this form here notice the K and
the X are multiplied together and
they're in the numerator so y varies
directly with the square root of x now
you always want to have a constant of
variation whether it's k or a or another
letter
and then inversely now inversely means
that the variable is going to go in the
denominator okay so inversely with the
cube root
cube root of Z and you got it so when I
write these problems what I sometimes
like to do is read through the problem
quickly just to get a general overview
and then go ahead and dive into the
details remember you always want to have
that constant variation I usually put it
in the numerator that's generally the
accepted way of writing it and then
remember Direct
it's in the numerator inverse that
quantity goes in the denominator and you
got it so for number six L varies
jointly
with the square root of Z and the cube
of R so joint means it's in this form
here y equals K times x times Z they're
all multiplied together notice they're
in the numerator and so if I was going
to write this now I would say l
varies put our constant of variation
with the square root of Z so the square
root of Z and the cube of R so R to the
third power not the cube root but the
cube so that's the third power notice
these are all multiplied together
they're all in the numerator we have our
constant of variation and you got it so
great job if you're able to follow this
variation video if you want more
practice learning about direct and
inverse and the different types of
variation and follow me over to a
previous video I did right there and
we'll get some more practice I'll see
you over there